>>Teacher: All right,
put your books away.
>>Children: Aw.
>>Katie: We know that
practice makes perfect.
Our kids need to read every
single night in order to get good
and we start them out in first grade.
But by fifth grade, they're hitting
their targets and they're up to two
and a half years above grade level
on the STAR reading assessment.
>>We really found that a lot of our
kids going home weren't finishing books.
They were, you know, reading
one chapter or fake reading
and not doing reading logs.
So we as a staff decided that we
would want all of our students
to at least read one series.
That's how we started.
>>Kris: We realized that we needed
to make it more incentivized
for the students, where they would
want to read, where it became
like a self motivation thing.
And our principal decided
that it needed to start young.
So we created these charm necklaces,
and every time they finish a
book series, they get a charm.
Those things are like gold to them.
>>Emmanuel: I really like to read.
I would read fifty books
a day if I had the time.
>>Katie: We know that when children
finish an entire series written
by the same author, that they
get to love and know a character.
And so we found that they increase
comprehension, increase practice
in reading and don't waste
time staring at a bookshelf.
>>Kris: When you see my class
read, they're engaged in the book.
You can see them like be in the story
and that's really what
we were going for.
Then we were like, okay, now are
they really understanding what
they're reading?
That's where Accelerated
Reader comes in, AR.
They take quizzes on books.
They get points, depending
on the size of the book
and the difficulty of the book.
>>Nevadisa: We don't use the small
box up here, but we use the big boxes.
There's twenty of them, and you need
twenty points to get a lucky ducky.
>>Katie: For reading, we
offer a lot of incentives.
We do lucky duckies if they
get twenty points in the month.
Then we also have trophies for
the class with the most AR points
of the month in each grade level.
>>Jamari? Braulio?
>>Braulio: As I said, I had
a good view of the stage,
and what I saw was quite unexpected.
>>Katie: Parents are
children's first teacher.
We need them on our team, we need them
to support what we're doing in school.
We need them to engage in discussions
about what books they're reading,
and share that same enthusiasm at
home for learning and excitement.
>>Lorena: To me, the way that I
see him is he wants to be the best.
Reading, math, AR test, AR points.
>>Braulio: Reading is one of my favorite
subjects in school, and also it helps
when some books are so interesting,
sometimes I actually feel
like that I'm in the book.
>>Student: She's starting
to get the sense
that he's just wanting
the money and the land.
>>Klaus: Okay, and then
couple that with what?
What's going on in her personal life?
>>Student: In her personal
life, her husband just died,
so why would she want another husband?
>>Klaus: So this is good.
So when you guys write your own novels,
that's the thing that I'm looking for.
Can you capture those
complexity of emotions?
>>By the time they get into
my classroom in fifth grade,
I would probably have guaranteed
that they had more hours than anybody
in the school district reading books.
That allows me to spend less time on
fluency and then I can spend more time
on the plot in the curriculum,
or in the character development,
because I'm not losing a
lot of time on the basics.
>>Elaine: Gamen, three point
nine, Ruben, four point zero,
so you just got a four, good job.
Vishnu, ten point eight.
>>Katie: That's awesome.
>>Elaine: How are you doing that?
>>Vishnu: I read these chapter
books that give five to six points.
>>Katie: Our reading is
just exponentially more
than what it ever was,
you know, six years ago.
And each year, they keep reading
more and it really does improve
that overall achievement and fluency
before they leave our school.